charles koch is one of the richest
people in the world
and depending on whom you ask he's a
titan of industry
a dark money political boogeyman
or the philosopher king of the
libertarian movement and although coke
isn't big on consuming cannabis himself
he's now going public with a long-held
belief cannabis should be legal
nationwide
and so he's putting his name and nearly
25 million dollars of his 45 billion
dollar fortune to influence criminal
justice reform and cannabis legalization
by the end of 2021.
charles koch is also a political
influencer right now he's being thought
of as the person who might be able to
span both sides of the aisle and
convince politicians to legalize
cannabis on the federal level
the criminal justice reform has been a
big issue for charles coke and the koch
network you know starting in 2015 he
asked his longtime general counsel at
koch industries mark holden to basically
start a campaign to um kind of bring
about a lot of reform in criminal
justice
you know and that was kind of like the
beginning of the strange bedfellows
arrangement where somebody like
charles koch and president obama you'd
never think they'd agree on anything but
um in criminal justice reform they
really found common ground
cannabis prohibition was kind of the
next step marijuana has been effectively
outlawed in america since 1937.
37 states have legalized medical use
and 70 of americans now believe that
cannabis should be federally legal
charles koch has a very libertarian view
when it comes to marijuana he sees
cannabis prohibition as a basic
infringement on personal freedom but he
also sees it as a destructive public
policy uh which adds to america's mass
incarceration problem he also thinks
like we've learned this lesson before uh
we've seen what alcohol prohibition did
which it didn't stop people from
drinking it created more crime because
when you criminalize something that is
widely used people don't stop using it
in july senate majority leader chuck
schumer and senators corey booker and
ron wyden introduced their long-awaited
federal legalization bill so basically
what schumer's bill does is give the
states the rights to legalize or
continue the ban but it lifts the ban
federally so empowering the states to do
what they want that's the definition of
states rights and definition of small
government so framed that way it's a
conservative issue it would be hard to
have a conservative kind of argue that
states rights is you know in their their
parties philosophy
however it's unclear whether or not this
bill could pass once formerly introduced
schumer readily admits he doesn't yet
have the numbers he needs at least 10
republican senators and all 50
democratic senators for it to pass
and another issue is that president
biden does not fully support
legalization
you know valerie jarrett senior adviser
to president obama told me somebody like
charles coke could be a person who kind
of brings both sides together the people
on the right especially who see charles
koch coming out on this issue that moves
the line uh what an interesting thing
that randall meyer this lobbyist said is
is that he's talked to over two dozen uh
politicians in congress on the right and
left and he says that coke has basically
given cover to people who were on the
fence you know what he believes what he
takes stances on really moves the needle
why he's doing this is really for
philosophical beliefs he's fighting for
criminal justice reform
because that's something he wants to do
and he has the resources to do it and
this issue of cannabis legalization
nicely dovetails into his philosophy
around criminal justice reform
you